o pessoal envolvido mais um vídeo e hoje
vou fazer uma coisa diferente e sempre
quis ter uma impressora 3d não estava
sendo aquela compra um conto como não
compro mais falando com a empresa bangu
de eu ser ok vamos mandar turma mas
desde que fazer um chuveiro ou seja este
vídeo é patrocinado pelo bangu se vocês
quiserem comprar uma impressora 3d de um
link na descrição e o filamento por isso
então vamos começar por montar a
emissora para começar a cobrir a caixa e
mostraram que ela trazia como vocês já
perceberam estava em tudo desmontado
talvez seja por isso que ela é muito
mais barata em comparação com outros
modelos
agora você já estará pronta daí mas se é
fácil montar o quanto tempo vai demorar
mais 20 45 horas e para montar nem muito
difícil uma vez que cada pecinha tem o
seu nome e sua letra e as partes de
metal que eu estou a propor também tem o
seu número e em termos de instrução
vocês têm suporte escrito e também em
vídeo da marca tem um mapa um canal no
youtube em que tem playlist para queda
impressora que existem à venda e por
fazer isto fui lá o canal de luz quer
ganhe nos vídeos fui fazendo vídeo por
vídeo era uma coisa que vocês vão
reparar que o perigo é que eu vou tirar
esses partidos centena de papel que está
colado nas peças eu pensava que isso não
tirá-lo porque está bem gravado
só que mais para frente eu estava vendo
o vídeo e payment systems preto eo
tanque com esta cor porque aí que eu
percebi que dava para tirar essa
inteligência sal
então eu tirei tudo e voltei a montar
para ficar com de ser bonito assim preto
e uma coisa muito engraçada que vi na
internet é que muitas pessoas fazem
outras impressoras utilizando a emissora
que os têm
ou seja estas pessoas que vocês estão
vendo aqui vocês conseguem encontrar
online conseguem baixar e mandou a
impressora fazer as próprias peças que
ela é feita e depois levam elas montam
outra emissora
a parte eletrônica é bastante fácil de
encontrar à venda e é bastante barato
também pelo que ouvi porque caso alguma
coisa se estraga vocês conseguem
substituir e vocês já conhecem nossa
própria impressora por foram vocês que
montaram ok
é isso é bem bacana aí estava com que em
menino início confesso mas depois fui
fazendo e quando começou o primeiro
fiquei super super contente
a itália também porque também é uma
coisa que eu sempre quis ter em casa e
isso embora daqui um canil fazer outra
coisa para imprimir tem outras idéias
agora uma coisa muito importante esta
coisa que não sei como é que chama de
borracha tem que ficar bem esticada para
não dar pois problemas quando for
imprimir ok porque é o plataforma tem
corresponder bahia o movimento do motor
pois são torneios o mover e a plataforma
não então ele vai ter problema na hora
de imprimir
eu diria que mostrei mais ou menos 50%
do que vocês têm que fazer e fiz isso
para não ficar muito chato e você também
tem informação do centro online então
pensei que não é uma coisa assim muito
necessária essa por vocês terem uma
idéia geral como funcionam as
impressoras e como é o processo de
montagem
agora vejam aqui que optei que os
parafusos muito bem só que não fiz no
vídeo porque ficou sem uma estranha não
estava com um cheiro banha chavo porque
era bastante grande mas é importante
vocês apertarem cada coisa muito bem
para que depois não se mover e e causar
problemas na hora de impressão e agora
vou por dois motores para o eixo z que
eu trabalho em simultâneo para ir levar
aquela plataforma que contenham estuda
que vocês vão ver daqui mais para frente
agora que eu vou encaixar isto e esta
parte em caixa e vai movimentar o z e
também o chique é do lado direito para a
esquerda da esquerda pra direita
encaixar o ecrã passou por lá que eu
colocar quatro parafusos e também teve
um botão que roda e também dá para
pilotar nela é a única coisa que vocês
conseguem usar para controlar a máquina
se quiserem primeiro manualmente porque
dá pra vocês por lá um cartão de memória
e carregar para imprimir
mas eu prefiro fazer tudo pelo
computador é o livro que eu via usb
o computador tem lá uma entrada no
arduino é pra vocês por lá outro lado do
cabo usb ea placa do arduino controla o
movimento dos anjos agora para os cabos
do arduino eu não gostei muito mas é
porque ela era uma grande confusão
não é que fosse confuso porque tem a
instrução em chamas está atípica no
mercado livre para onde vocês vão ter
que encaixar é só que como eu estava lá
e fazer aquilo e muito cabo não foi
preciso muito bem então deixei não
filmar essa parte do comércio está
informação do senta aí o que vai colocar
um pedaço de vidro porque vi muitas
pessoas que punham então se importando
aí é como não encontrei nenhum lugar à
venda para cortar assim prometida então
terei de uma moldura e é muito
importante para finalizar vocês
calibrarem esta mesa de forma que os
tubérculos movimentar num toque na
plataforma tem ficar assim
é uma pequena distância do tamanho da
folha e agora no partido computador a
primeira coisa tem que fazer instalar os
drivers de impressora mas é bastante
simples basta você conectar em
impressora eo s p os computadores
instalados automaticamente se vocês
tiverem internet é bastante simples
depois tem que estar o programa
retirou-se de 70 90 que é da mesma
companhia da impressora que vem nas
instruções como baixar um baixar essas
coisas todas
e depois precisar muita coisa mudou
desde claro agora que o meu filho estava
se apresentando para simular então tem
duas opções vocês fazem os vossos
próprios
existem programas gratuitos para isso
como o google sketchup o blend e os
problemas para cruzar de maia que é pago
e bem pago é mas eu sou estudante
antônio estão estudando o que é bastante
ou então podem baixar na internet que
existem muitos muitos websites que vocês
podem lá baixar gratuitamente e pois
mandar pra você impressora e já está
feita mas o google sketchup aprendendo
um dia de boa foi o primeiro problema
que eu aprendi que o documento vai
começar a cair
quando você estiver ao vosso objeto é só
mandar para impressora e que ela vai
ficar a emissora o programa da emissora
e eu que vai fazer primeiramente fazer
os cálculos para dividir o objeto porque
malas e depois que os tanques também vou
ensinar fla coisa bastante simples
também vai dividir porque uma linha
quando fizeram os cálculos tudo sair
vocês querem imprimir e foi buscar o
objeto outro lado pessoal
vamos ver quem vai sair eo ao
treinamento mesmo deu para eu ficar me
ora quem é parte má mas eu vou comparar
os no final pra vocês verem a diferença
então vamos lá ver o que vai sair de
aprofundamento para dar o melhor à mesa
eu coloquei um pouco de spray protetor
de veículos ao punho e pôs também e
agora vocês conseguem ver um processo de
impressão e achei bastante bom e
imprimir duas maneiras 50% o que fazer
se uma era repor dentro e 0% que fica
100% preenchido é aí que vocês conseguem
ver os dois modelos com o segundo teste
a bola tinha que segurar melhor o
elástico e chegamos ao fim só agora para
finalizar vou mostrar só como usar no
física tipo esta porque vocês podem
fazer usando coisas bastante simples até
aí então precisaram de folhas dos boxes
notas que já vem com tamanho bastante
com eu fazer uma rifa assim aqui nós
vamos usar óculos de proteção e eu vou
esperar aqui pra você e como funciona
tendo portanto bom
quero deixar um like